This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the early 1970s, when March of Unputing was 21 years old, she lived in an apartment with her young kid in the middle of Amsterdam. It was right on a busy road and there was always a lot of traffic. I remember there was a nearby school and you could see before 9 o'clock before the school start children on their bikes crossing that road to go to school at the other side of that busy road. Marcha worried about the kids on their bikes.
这里是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。20世纪70年代初，当玛莎·范·普滕（Marcha van Puetten）21岁时，她带着年幼的孩子住在阿姆斯特丹市中心的一间公寓里。公寓正对着一条繁忙的马路，车流量总是很大。我记得附近有一所学校，在9点上课前，你可以看到孩子们骑着自行车穿过那条繁忙的马路去上学。玛莎很担心那些骑车的孩子。
Once in a while there were accidents. And one day she heard a collision out on the street. Some people were screaming and other cars had to stop and you could hear their alarms and things. So then you run to the window and you see what's happening. A girl about eight years old had been trying across the street and got hit by a car. She was luckily not so seriously hidden that she had to be transferred to in a hospital, but she was hit and the bike was broken.
偶尔会发生事故。有一天，她听到街上传来碰撞声。有人在尖叫，其他汽车不得不停下来，你可以听到警报声之类的声音。于是你跑到窗边看发生了什么事。一个大约八岁的小女孩在过马路时被车撞了。幸运的是，她伤得不算太重，不需要送往医院，但她确实被撞了，自行车也坏了。
And there was a lady at that time, an old lady, someone as I am now, an old lady with an umbrella, like this Mary Poppins sort of type. Margea watched as the Mary Poppins lady approached the driver of the car. She took the point of her umbrella and she poked it right into a stomach. And she was screaming at him
当时有一位老太太，像我现在这个年纪，一位打着雨伞的老太太，有点像玛丽·波平斯（Mary Poppins）那种类型。玛莎看着那位“玛丽·波平斯”女士走向肇事司机。她用雨伞尖戳了戳他的肚子，并对他大声尖叫。
and I was standing at the window and you could see what was happening. That kind of things, you know, you don't forget. In the early 1970s, this kind of collision was all too common. Producer Delaney Hall. There were more cars on the Dutch roads than ever before, and the roads were getting more dangerous. Growing numbers of pedestrians, bicyclists, and drivers were dying and wrecks. People like the Mary Poppins woman, and Marcia, and many, many others, were getting fed up.
我当时站在窗边，能看到发生了什么。那种事，你知道，你是不会忘记的。在20世纪70年代初，这种碰撞太常见了。制片人德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。荷兰道路上的汽车比以往任何时候都多，道路也变得越来越危险。越来越多的行人、骑自行车的人和司机在车祸中丧生。像那位“玛丽·波平斯”女士、玛莎以及许多许多其他人，都受够了。
That was exactly the feeling we had. Something went wrong over time. We said, what did we do over the years? And why is it that the car is always number one? I have never actually been to the Netherlands, but the story doesn't fit with my impression of the country. It was surprising to me to hear that cars were ever number one in a city like Amsterdam. Today, the Netherlands has a reputation as a kind of bicycling paradise.
那正是我们的感受。随着时间的推移，有些事情出了差错。我们说，这些年来我们都做了些什么？为什么汽车总是排在第一位？我其实从未去过荷兰，但这个故事与我对这个国家的印象不符。听到在阿姆斯特丹这样的城市里，汽车曾经排在第一位，我感到很惊讶。如今，荷兰被誉为骑行天堂。
Dutch people today own more bicycles per capita than any other place in the world. The country has more than 20,000 miles of dedicated cycling paths. International policymakers make pilgrimages to the Netherlands to learn how to create good bike infrastructure. But none of that was inevitable. It wasn't something that magically emerged from Dutch culture. In the 1960s and 70s, back when Marcha was a young mom, it looked like the Netherlands would follow the same path as the United States.
如今荷兰人均拥有的自行车数量比世界上任何地方都多。全国拥有超过2万英里的专用自行车道。国际政策制定者纷纷前往荷兰，学习如何打造优秀的自行车基础设施。但这一切并非必然。这并不是从荷兰文化中神奇地涌现出来的。在20世纪60和70年代，当玛莎还是个年轻妈妈时，荷兰看起来似乎要走上和美国一样的道路。
The Dutch had fallen in love with cars, and they were rebuilding their cities to make room for them. Bicycles were fading away. But then, in one of the great comeback stories of our time, building their cities to make room for them. Bicycles were fading away. But then, in one of the great comeback stories of our time, bikes fought their way back. And one of the reasons why was marcha. The Netherlands is an amazing place to ride a bike.
荷兰人爱上了汽车，他们正在重建城市，为汽车腾出空间。自行车正在逐渐消失。但随后，在我们这个时代最伟大的复兴故事之一中，自行车杀回来了。原因之一就是玛莎。荷兰是一个非常适合骑自行车的地方。
The country is as flat as a pancake, and temperatures are mild for a good part of the year. So when bicycles first started getting popular in Europe in the 1920s, they really took off in the Netherlands, launching the country's first golden age of cycling. We have images of that. After 1920s and 30s, people enjoying the city, we have moving images of these cyclists, you know, going back and forth over the trim tracks and really playing, being playful and enjoying the city. This is Ruth Oldenzeal, a historian who studied cycling in the Netherlands, and she says that
这个国家平坦如煎饼，一年中大部分时间气温都很温和。因此，当自行车在20世纪20年代首次在欧洲流行起来时，它们在荷兰真正火了起来，开启了该国自行车运动的第一个黄金时代。我们有那时的影像。20世纪20和30年代后，人们享受着城市生活，我们有这些骑行者的动态影像，你知道，他们在电车轨道上来回穿梭，玩耍嬉戏，享受着城市。这是露丝·奥尔登泽尔（Ruth Oldenzeel），一位研究荷兰自行车运动的历史学家，她说
in the 1920s and 30s, bicycles became the main form of transport for many Dutch people. Some cities even started building bike paths. The popularity of cycling dipped briefly during World War II, but then continued its climb into the 1950s. And because streets were relatively safe during these decades, kids got used to a surprising degree of freedom. We were always outside, and we blayed into streets.
在20世纪20和30年代，自行车成为许多荷兰人的主要交通工具。一些城市甚至开始修建自行车道。二战期间，自行车运动的普及率略有下降，但随后在20世纪50年代继续攀升。由于这些年代街道相对安全，孩子们习惯了令人惊讶的自由度。我们总是在外面玩，在街上玩耍。
When Martha was a girl, she and her friends learned to ride bikes as soon as they possibly could. By four or five years old, they were riding independently through their neighborhoods. Streets were our territory. They'd zoom around on bikes and gather at the one house in the neighborhood
玛莎小时候，她和朋友们一学会骑自行车就立刻骑车。四五岁时，他们就能独立骑车穿过社区。街道是我们的领地。他们骑着自行车四处飞驰，聚集在社区里唯一一户
that had a television. It was the first TV Marcia had ever seen. The kids would just toss their bikes in the yard and go inside to watch kids shows and eat cookies. Neighborhoods were kids grow up without traffic. Kids learn to know each other. They meet each other and you do it. But in the 1950s and 60s, things started to change.
有电视的人家。那是玛莎见过的第一台电视。孩子们会把自行车扔在院子里，跑进屋里看儿童节目、吃饼干。社区里的孩子们在没有交通干扰的情况下长大。孩子们互相认识。他们见面，一起玩耍。但在20世纪50和60年代，情况开始发生变化。
There was a new wave of urban planners on the rise, and they saw bikes as a relic of the past. World War II was over. Europe was rebuilding. People were buying lots of cars. And Dutch cities with their narrow cobblestone streets would need to be totally redesigned to make way for the vehicle of the future. We have a lot of historic cities, Amsterdam being one, and of
新一代城市规划者正在崛起，他们将自行车视为过去的遗物。二战结束了。欧洲正在重建。人们购买了大量的汽车。而荷兰城市及其狭窄的鹅卵石街道需要彻底重新设计，以便为未来的交通工具让路。我们有很多历史名城，阿姆斯特丹就是其中之一，当然
course a city in order to accommodate cars. You had to destruct a lot of neighborhoods, and so there were these ridiculous modernist plans to basically erase historic neighborhoods to make a space for cars. There were a number of plans proposed in the 1950s and 60s. In one case, the Dutch car lobby hired an American traffic engineer by the name of David Yokinan. He was supposed to come in and revolutionize the hagg and Amsterdam. In Amsterdam, Yokinin wanted to demolish a number of the city's working-class neighborhoods. He also wanted to fill in one of the city's iconic canals with concrete in order to build a six-lane highway into the city center.
为了容纳汽车，你必须拆毁许多社区，所以当时有一些荒谬的现代主义计划，基本上是为了给汽车腾出空间而抹去历史街区。20世纪50和60年代提出了一些计划。有一次，荷兰汽车游说团体聘请了一位名叫大卫·约基南（David Yokinan）的美国交通工程师。他本应来彻底改变海牙和阿姆斯特丹。在阿姆斯特丹，约基南想要拆除该市的一些工人阶级社区。他还想用混凝土填平该市标志性的运河之一，以便修建一条通往市中心的六车道高速公路。
Yokinin assumed that, just like in the U.S., most people would want to live in the suburbs and drive to work. Many people were not into this plan. They didn't want to see the old city torn down and transformed into a landscape of concrete tower blocks and mega-freeways. He became the perfect enemy of the local movement. You know, he was this brash, stupid American.
约基南认为，就像在美国一样，大多数人会想住在郊区并开车上班。许多人并不赞同这个计划。他们不想看到古老的城市被拆毁，变成一片混凝土塔楼和超级高速公路的景观。他成了当地运动的完美敌人。你知道，他就是那个傲慢、愚蠢的美国人。
He was ignorant about local situations. To his opponents, Yokenin was like this cartoonish, super villain, city planner. And he helped unite a misfit coalition of groups who rallied together to fight against his modernist schemes. These very different groups would ultimately help launch the cycling revolution
他对当地情况一无所知。在反对者眼中，约基南就像是一个卡通式的超级反派城市规划者。他帮助团结了一个由不同群体组成的“乌合之众”联盟，他们联合起来反对他的现代主义计划。这些截然不同的群体最终帮助发起了自行车革命，
in the Netherlands. First, there were the local elites who had deep roots in Amsterdam. Like the Nimbi preservationists of today, this group of old money Amsterdamers loved the historic character of the city. And for many decades, since the country had begun to industrialize,
在荷兰。首先，有在阿姆斯特丹根基深厚的当地精英。就像今天的“邻避”（NIMBY）保护主义者一样，这群老派阿姆斯特丹人热爱这座城市的历史特色。几十年来，自从国家开始工业化以来，
they'd been advocating to protect historic neighborhoods and buildings. They were really proud of their city. They were organizing. They were supporting preservation of the city. Old stuff. Alongside the preservationists, a number of more radical movements began to take shape,
他们一直倡导保护历史街区和建筑。他们为自己的城市感到自豪。他们在组织起来。他们在支持保护城市。那些老东西。在保护主义者旁边，一些更激进的运动开始形成，
including a group of anarchists called Provo. They declared their opposition to quote, capitalism, communism, fascism, bureaucracy, militarism, professionalism, dogmatism, and authoritarianism. To give you a sense of their vibe, they once published instructions for how to make a bomb out of a pineapple. The Provo's were not fans of the new wave of modernist planners. They didn't want their cities becoming car-centric machines. One of them denounced traffic as a pagan god
包括一个叫“Provo”的无政府主义团体。他们宣布反对所谓的“资本主义、共产主义、法西斯主义、官僚主义、军国主义、专业主义、教条主义和威权主义”。为了让你感受一下他们的风格，他们曾经发布过如何用菠萝制作炸弹的说明。Provo并不是新一代现代主义规划者的粉丝。他们不希望自己的城市变成以汽车为中心的机器。其中一人谴责交通是异教神，
that the Dutch sacrificed multiple people a day to. At first, the provost were mostly protesting in the streets, but as they got more popular, they moved into politics, even winning a number of seats on the Amsterdam City Council. There, they proposed a number of seats on the Amsterdam City Council. There they proposed a number of policies to rid the City Center of cars, including what was one of the first bicycle sharing programs in the world, the white bicycles. And the white bicycle was simply a Dutch, a rickety, upright bicycle, one gear, nothing
荷兰人每天都要向它献祭多人。起初，Provo主要是在街头抗议，但随着他们越来越受欢迎，他们进入了政坛，甚至在阿姆斯特丹市议会赢得了几个席位。在那里，他们提出了一些政策，旨在清除市中心的汽车，包括世界上最早的自行车共享计划之一——“白自行车”。而“白自行车”只是一辆普通的荷兰自行车，破旧、直立、单速，没什么
special. This is Marco Tibermelstrut, a professor at the University of Amsterdam and a co-founder of the Urban Cycling Institute. And what he describes is pretty different from your average corporate city bike program of today. By painting it white, people could offer their bike to the community. Those bikes would not be locked, they would be free floating through the city, and basically everybody could join.
特别的。这是马可·蒂伯梅尔斯特鲁特（Marco te Brömmelstroet），阿姆斯特丹大学教授，城市自行车研究所的联合创始人。他所描述的与今天一般的企业城市自行车计划大不相同。通过把它漆成白色，人们可以把自己的自行车贡献给社区。这些自行车不会上锁，它们会在城市中自由流动，基本上每个人都可以加入。
For the provost, the bicycle became not just a practical transportation device, but an important symbol. If the car represented speed and capitalism, then the bike represented the opposite, something slow and humble. The provost said, the bicycle is nothing. The feet is neat, it rhymes. And what they were playing on, it was this notion of the bicycle be very vulnerable. The symbol of the bike really was about a whole new way of organizing society. And it was picked up especially by artists.
对于Provo来说，自行车不仅是一种实用的交通工具，更是一个重要的象征。如果汽车代表速度和资本主义，那么自行车就代表相反的东西，一种缓慢而谦逊的东西。Provo说，“自行车什么都不是，双脚才整洁”，这还押韵。他们利用的是自行车非常脆弱这一概念。自行车的象征意义实际上是关于一种组织社会的新方式。它尤其受到艺术家的青睐。
Hello. Hello. Hello. One of the most visible examples of this way of organizing society and it was picked up especially by artists. One of the most visible examples of this was in 1969 when John Lennon and Yoko Ono spent their honeymoon in Amsterdam. This was their famous bed in for peace. Where they lay around in a bed for a week and had lots of iconic photographs taken. In those photos, you can see John and Yoko in bed in their white bathrooms with a white dove in a bird cage sitting nearby and in front of them, a white bicycle. Why did you choose Amsterdam today, 7 days in a row?
你好。你好。你好。这种组织社会方式最明显的例子之一，尤其受到艺术家的青睐。其中最明显的例子之一是1969年，约翰·列侬（John Lennon）和小野洋子（Yoko Ono）在阿姆斯特丹度蜜月。这就是他们著名的“床上和平运动”（Bed-in for peace）。他们在床上躺了一个星期，拍了很多标志性的照片。在那些照片中，你可以看到约翰和洋子躺在白色的浴室里，旁边放着一个鸟笼，里面有一只白鸽，在他们面前，是一辆白色的自行车。你们为什么选择阿姆斯特丹，连续7天？
Because it's one of those important, you know, sensitive, with the provoles and the white buyers of all of them. With the details we don't know, we just pick up the vibrations. You know, it's hard to believe that you do. The provos eventually inspired other groups, like the troublesome Amsterdamers and the cabotters, who created something called the Car Elimination Service. They would ride their bikes through the city, blocking traffic, and reclaiming the streets
因为它是那些重要、敏感的地方之一，有Provo和白自行车，所有这些。细节我们不知道，我们只是接收到了共鸣。你知道，很难相信你们会这样做。Provo最终激励了其他团体，比如“麻烦的阿姆斯特丹人”（Troublesome Amsterdammers）和“Cabotters”，他们创建了一个名为“汽车消除服务”（Car Elimination Service）的组织。他们会骑着自行车穿过城市，阻挡交通，并夺回街道，
for bicycles. But even though the preservationists and the anarchists were a formidable alliance in the war on cars, in the big picture, the automobile was still winning. Between 1960 and 1970, the number of cars in the country quadrupled and the rates of bicycling plummeted. Traffic casualties were way, way up. By the early 70s, over 3,000 people were dying in traffic collisions every year in the Netherlands.
让自行车通行。但尽管保护主义者和无政府主义者在反汽车战争中是一个强大的联盟，但从大局来看，汽车仍然在获胜。在1960年到1970年间，该国的汽车数量翻了两番，自行车骑行率直线下降。交通伤亡人数大幅上升。到70年代初，荷兰每年有超过3000人死于交通事故。
Hundreds of those people were kids, and even more of them were getting injured. The kind of collision that Marcia witnessed from her apartment window had become commonplace. This was true all over the world as cars became more popular. And in many places like the US, people learned to just tolerate this new baseline of traffic-related injuries and deaths. But that didn't happen in the Netherlands. The Dutch decided that losing that many children to cars
其中数百人是儿童，受伤的人数更多。玛莎从公寓窗户目睹的那种碰撞已经变得司空见惯。随着汽车越来越普及，这种情况在世界各地都是如此。在许多地方，比如美国，人们学会了忍受这种新的交通相关伤害和死亡的基准线。但这并没有在荷兰发生。荷兰人决定，失去这么多孩子给汽车，
was a price they were unwilling to pay. The catalyzing event happened in October 1971. When a six-year-old girl named Simona Longenhof was cycling to school near the city of Aindhoven about an hour and a half south of Amsterdam, a driver speeding around abandoned the road, hit and killed her. op de stad van Eindhoven, op een houdste zout van Amsterdam. Een drijfers beelden op de band in de roud, het en kielter. Dat was gebeurd in helftwoord op een provinciale weg.
是他们不愿付出的代价。催化事件发生在1971年10月。当一个名叫西蒙娜·隆根霍夫（Simona Longenhof）的六岁女孩在阿姆斯特丹以南约一个半小时车程的埃因霍温市附近骑车上学时，一名超速行驶的司机在路边撞死了她。
De vader was een prominent journalist, namelijk Wic long en half. Hier is hij een documenter van de 90's. In de eerste instantie ben je dan zo'n kapot dat je, het is het jaar eigenlijk helemaal niet, kunnen bedenken wat je daar. In the Eastern Instance de Béder, so it could voltage you. Yeah, it is. Yeah, I had a car money. Couldn't be thinking what you did. And I actually overzoved. At first, you are so broken that you can't really think of what you would do about it. That only came after a year.
她的父亲是一位著名的记者，名叫维克·隆根霍夫（Vic Longenhof）。这是他在90年代的一部纪录片中讲述的。起初，你崩溃了，你甚至无法思考你会怎么做。那是一年之后的事了。起初，你太痛苦了，以至于你无法真正思考该怎么做。那是一年之后才有的想法。
A year later, one of Vick's other kids was struck by a car. And thankfully, they weren't seriously harmed. But when Vic was approached by a group of I'mhove and parents who'd been campaigning for safer routes to school, he decided to write an article about his experience. It ran on the front page of the newspaper he worked for. He wrote that society cared more about advertising products to kids than protecting their actual health and safety.
一年后，维克的另一个孩子被车撞了。谢天谢地，他们没有受到严重伤害。但当一群一直为争取更安全上学路线而奔走的埃因霍温家长找到维克时，他决定写一篇关于自己经历的文章。文章刊登在他工作的报纸头版。他写道，社会关心向孩子们推销产品，胜过保护他们的实际健康和安全。
He said that children had to navigate unsafe roads because there was no business interest pushing to make the roads better. Is there no pressure group he wrote? Then let's make one. A Stark headline ran at the top of the article. Stop De kindermord. Stop the child murder. That article on the front page. The whole page with thick letters.
他说，孩子们不得不穿行在不安全的道路上，因为没有商业利益推动改善道路。他写道，没有压力团体吗？那就让我们成立一个。文章顶部有一个醒目的标题。“Stop de kindermoord”。停止杀害儿童。那篇文章在头版。整整一页都是粗体大字。
Here's Mar-Chev Van Poetten again. She still remembers seeing Vic's story in the newspaper when she was a young mother living in Amsterdam in that apartment on the busy road. I think he was confronting the readers with sort of language as this is what we do with our children. How crazy are we? Angry, he was angry, and people reading it got angry too. He realized what was happening. So it doesn't alarm Bell.
这是玛莎·范·普滕。当她还是个住在阿姆斯特丹那条繁忙马路旁公寓里的年轻母亲时，她仍然记得在报纸上看到维克的故事。我想他是在用这种语言质问读者：这就是我们对待孩子的方式吗？我们有多疯狂？他很愤怒，读到这篇文章的人也感到愤怒。他意识到发生了什么。所以这敲响了警钟。
That's for how the Thrukin has a bomb. Well, that story, it hit like a bomb. I then received so many responses from all over the country, from parents whose children had also had accidents or near accidents. And I was one of those that called him, can we help? Can we do something? Not long after he published the article, Vic traveled to Amsterdam. He met with Marcia and a number of other parents, and they decided to organize a protest using
那就像一颗炸弹。嗯，那个故事，它像炸弹一样轰动。我随后收到了来自全国各地的许多回应，来自那些孩子也发生过事故或险些发生事故的家长。我是打电话给他的其中一人，我们可以帮忙吗？我们可以做点什么吗？文章发表后不久，维克前往阿姆斯特丹。他会见了玛莎和其他几位家长，他们决定组织一场抗议活动，使用
tactics similar to the provosts and the cabalters. This time, instead of rowdy anarchists, it was a bunch of parents and kids. They decided to stage their first action. On the exact street where Marcia had witnessed the Mary Poppins woman, chastising a driver for nearly killing a kid. And we said, okay, this big street in front of my house, where those accidents were sometimes happening, we said we have to block it. During rush hour, shall I show you the picture? The day of the protest, they showed up and went out into the street.
类似于Provo和Cabotters的策略。这一次，不再是吵闹的无政府主义者，而是一群家长和孩子。他们决定举行第一次行动。就在玛莎目睹那位“玛丽·波平斯”女士斥责一名差点撞死孩子的司机的那条街上。我们说，好吧，我家门前这条大马路，有时会发生那些事故，我们说我们必须封锁它。在高峰时段，我给你看照片吗？抗议当天，他们出现并走上街头。
They made a big circle holding hands. In the picture, it looks like they're skipping or dancing. That's so beautiful to see. It's mostly women and a few children you see here. I'm one in the middle here. This is me. I'm not sure if we were singing, but very friendly. And the police let us do it.
他们手拉手围成一个大圆圈。在照片里，看起来他们像是在跳跃或跳舞。看到这一幕真是太美了。这里大部分是女性和几个孩子。我在中间这里。这是我。我不确定我们当时是否在唱歌，但非常友好。警察让我们这么做了。
They let us do it. That was also the mood, the society, and the stout what we were doing. That image ended up on the front page of the main newspaper in Amsterdam the next day. And quickly, the movement began to grow. They took their name from the headline on VIX article. Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop other groups of parents sprang up in other parts of the country. They all operated independently, but they kept in touch with each other and shared ideas about how to generate attention. Vic long enough again.
他们让我们这么做了。那也是当时的情绪，社会，以及我们所做的事情。第二天，那张照片登上了阿姆斯特丹主要报纸的头版。运动很快开始壮大。他们从维克文章的标题中取了名字：Stop de Kindermoord。其他地方的家长团体也在全国其他地区涌现。他们各自独立运作，但保持联系并分享如何引起关注的想法。维克·隆根霍夫再次说道。
Yeah, every time an other kid got hit by a car, we were on top of it right away, to offer some comfort, but above all to immediately identify what caused it, what is the situation like in that town or province. And then immediately, another action would happen and people became active on the spot and supported. That worked like a snowball. Vick eventually left the movement. He was busy with parenting and writing, but he encouraged Stop to Kindermort to keep
是的，每次有其他孩子被车撞，我们都会立即跟进，提供一些安慰，但最重要的是立即查明原因，那个城镇或省份的情况如何。然后，立即会有另一次行动，人们在现场变得活跃并给予支持。这就像滚雪球一样。维克最终离开了这场运动。他忙于育儿和写作，但他鼓励“停止杀害儿童”继续
going, and Marcheup became the organization's first chair. Like all good protest movements, Stop to Kindermort was good at highlighting the madness of the status quo. The parents involved would show up at protests, carrying images hand-drawn by their kids, showing scenes of traffic violence. And while the group was asking for something pretty basic for kids to be able to move freely and safely through their cities, they were still trying to upend the dominance of the car, and they sometimes face opposition. I'm going to disguise my knowledge, day and it's going to burn,
进行下去，玛莎成为了该组织的第一任主席。像所有优秀的抗议运动一样，Stop de Kindermoord擅长突出这种现状的疯狂。参与的家长会出现在抗议活动中，带着孩子们手绘的图片，展示交通暴力的场景。虽然该组织要求的是一些非常基本的东西——让孩子们能够安全自由地在城市中穿行，但他们仍然试图颠覆汽车的统治地位，有时也会面临阻力。
it's going to burn, it's going to burn. In the answer to a neighborhood of Depeite, a group of parents and children wanted to close the street to cars, so that kids there would have a place to play. In a documentary made in 1972, you can see people dragging and barricading to the street to block cars. And then a driver getting out and angrily dragging it away.
在代尔夫特的一个社区，一群家长和孩子想要关闭街道，禁止汽车通行，这样孩子们就有地方玩耍。在1972年制作的一部纪录片中，你可以看到人们拖着路障封锁街道。然后一名司机下车，愤怒地把路障拖走。
Then two adults shoving each other in the street. Marja says that this kind of thing happened a lot. You sold aggressive reactions of the drivers of cars, maybe on the way to work, opening the window, screaming to us, go away, what are you doing here? But she says that just as often, people walking by would stop and help the protesters. They were really going to the windows of those cars and screaming back, saying, could be your kid tomorrow. And it created really big discussions.
然后两个成年人在街上推搡。玛莎说这种事经常发生。你会看到汽车司机表现出攻击性，也许是在上班路上，摇下车窗，对我们尖叫：“走开，你们在这里干什么？”但她说，同样经常有路人停下来帮助抗议者。他们真的走到那些车窗前反击，说：“明天可能是你的孩子。”这引发了非常大的讨论。
And we had this all over the place, not only in Amsterdam, but also in other cities. One thing that struck me as I interviewed old activists and watched protest footage is how unexpectedly joyful a lot of it seemed. I mean, the group was serious, obviously. They called themselves stop the child murder. But they also managed to make their work seem fun. All in for a general.
我们在各地都有这种情况，不仅在阿姆斯特丹，在其他城市也是如此。在采访老活动家和观看抗议录像时，有一件事让我印象深刻，那就是其中许多看起来出人意料地欢乐。我的意思是，这个团体显然是严肃的。他们自称“停止杀害儿童”。但他们也设法让他们的工作看起来很有趣。
For instance, they inspired Demetri Von Torin, a famous Dutch musician at the time to write a song for the movement. It got a lot of airtime on Dutch radio stations. In the group stayed the bicycle ride from the center of Amsterdam to the Prime Minister's house and the outskirts of the city. One of them had a street organ on wheels. In the Netherlands, you have those organs on wheels. And having the music in the streets of people came out of the houses, what's happening here so much, it took their bikes and joined us.
例如，他们激励了当时著名的荷兰音乐家德米特里·冯·托林（Demetri Von Torin）为该运动写了一首歌。它在荷兰广播电台获得了大量的播放时间。该团体组织了从阿姆斯特丹市中心到郊区首相官邸的自行车骑行活动。其中一个人带着一架轮式街头风琴。在荷兰，你有那种轮式风琴。街上有音乐，人们从房子里出来，问“这里发生了什么？”，然后骑上自行车加入了我们。
When they arrived, the Prime Minister greeted them in the front yard, served the kids' cookies, and invited them to come to his office later. Marja says they eventually spoke for a couple of hours about traffic safety. By this time, partly thanks to the protests, it was becoming clear to the Dutch government that there were real drawbacks to fully embracing the car. Not just in terms of casualties, but also the huge expense of building roads. In 1972, a Dutch research group released a study predicting it would cost billions of dollars to build out the infrastructure required for cars.
当他们到达时，首相在院子里迎接他们，给孩子们分发饼干，并邀请他们稍后去他的办公室。玛莎说，他们最终谈了几个小时关于交通安全的问题。到那时，部分得益于抗议活动，荷兰政府开始清楚地认识到，全面拥抱汽车有真正的弊端。不仅是在伤亡方面，还有修建道路的巨大开支。1972年，一个荷兰研究小组发布了一项研究，预测修建汽车所需的基础设施将耗资数十亿美元。
The study's political effect was huge. Pretty much everyone agreed that building that many roads wasn't feasible, and they needed to look for alternatives in the form of bikes and public transit. And then, a turn of geopolitical events helped the whole country see what life could be like with fewer cars. In late 1973, the oil crisis hit the Netherlands. The Dutch government wanted people to use less gas and so they created a series of car-free Sundays
这项研究的政治影响是巨大的。几乎每个人都同意，修建那么多道路是不可行的，他们需要寻找自行车和公共交通形式的替代方案。然后，地缘政治事件的转折帮助整个国家看到了汽车减少后的生活会是什么样子。1973年底，石油危机袭击了荷兰。荷兰政府希望人们少用汽油，因此他们设立了一系列“无车星期日”，
where they banned the use of private vehicles. There are incredible pictures from that time of kids riding their bikes down empty freeways, or people having picnics in the middle of wide roads with live flute accompaniment. Bus and train use sort. Marjoso remembers how different Amsterdam smelled on those days. Must have been a much more healthy air because the cars in those days had still let in their petrol. I remember one was when it was snowing in those days we still had
禁止使用私家车。当时有一些令人难以置信的照片，孩子们在空荡荡的高速公路上骑自行车，或者人们在宽阔的马路中间野餐，伴随着现场长笛演奏。公交车和火车的使用量激增。玛莎还记得阿姆斯特丹在那些日子里闻起来有多么不同。空气一定健康得多，因为当时的汽车还在使用含铅汽油。我记得有一次下雪的时候，那时候我们还有
real snow. Kids were out on the streets in the snow making snow dolls you know with carrots as a nose in the middle of streets it was great. The Carfrey Sundays gave everyone a chance to experience street life in a new way. Bicycle shops sold out of bikes as people rushed to buy them again, and all this momentum helps at the stage for the next phase of the Dutch cycling revolution. For a long time in the Netherlands, the conversation around pedestrian and bike safety had focused on the behavior of pedestrians and cyclists. The emphasis was on making sure you used the correct hand signals and understood traffic laws.
真正的雪。孩子们在雪地里走上街头，堆雪人，你知道，用胡萝卜做鼻子，在街道中间，真是太棒了。“无车星期日”让每个人都有机会以一种新的方式体验街道生活。自行车店的自行车被抢购一空，人们再次争相购买，所有这些势头为荷兰自行车革命的下一阶段奠定了基础。长期以来，在荷兰，关于行人和自行车安全的讨论一直集中在行人和骑行者的行为上。重点是确保你使用了正确的手势并理解交通法规。
Marcia says that one of the country's main traffic safety groups took that approach. They were called safe traffic Netherlands in English. That group was focusing always on, especially for children, on the behavior. Put them in a yellow coat, all the drivers will see them. You know, this sharp yellow plastic coat. But for anyone who spent even and afternoon with a young child, the limits of the behavioral approach are pretty obvious. When it comes to impulse control, an excited kid ranks just below a dog that has seen a squirrel. And if you're the adult responsible for their safety, and there are two tonn hunks of metal hurling by, it makes you stressed.
玛莎说，该国主要的交通安全组织之一采取了这种方法。他们叫“安全交通荷兰”（Safe Traffic Netherlands）。那个组织总是专注于行为，特别是针对儿童。给他们穿上黄色外套，所有的司机都会看到他们。你知道，这种鲜艳的黄色塑料外套。但对于任何与幼儿相处过哪怕一个下午的人来说，行为方法的局限性是显而易见的。当谈到冲动控制时，一个兴奋的孩子排名仅次于看到松鼠的狗。如果你是负责他们安全的成年人，而旁边有两吨重的金属块呼啸而过，这会让你感到压力。
Marja says she used to drill her kids. Just cross the road looking to the left, looking to the right, you train them. And while putting a yellow coat on your kid and teaching them to look both ways is of course not a bad idea. It was also clear to Marcia that the educational approach wasn't nearly enough. And more than that, it was asking the wrong people, parents and little kids to solve the problem. If you focus only on that, you don't discuss how is the road constructed?
玛莎说她过去常训练她的孩子。过马路时看着左边，看着右边，你训练他们。虽然给你的孩子穿上黄色外套并教他们看两边当然不是坏主意。但玛莎也很清楚，教育方法远远不够。更重要的是，它是在要求错误的人——家长和小孩——来解决这个问题。如果你只关注这一点，你就不会讨论道路是如何建造的？
Where is the space for the bikers? And how is the behavior of small children taken into the design of a road? Instead of trying to change how people acted, they needed to build something different. By the mid-1970s, the Netherlands had taken steps towards making the country's roads more friendly to cyclists. Some communities started charging steep prices for parking in their central districts, or they just banned cars from those areas outright. And others had started building special residential neighborhoods called Vonerfs, which means living street. Those areas required cars to move slowly at the speed of pedestrians and cyclists. There were also some intriguing experiments with bike paths,
自行车手的空间在哪里？小孩子的行为是如何被纳入道路设计的？他们不需要试图改变人们的行为，而是需要建造不同的东西。到70年代中期，荷兰已经采取措施，使该国的道路对骑行者更加友好。一些社区开始对市中心的停车收取高昂费用，或者干脆直接禁止汽车进入这些区域。其他人则开始建造被称为“Woonerf”（居住街道）的特殊住宅区。这些区域要求汽车以行人和骑行者的速度缓慢行驶。还有一些关于自行车道的有趣实验，
happening in places like the Hague, Tilburg, and Delft. But still, for many cycling activists, it felt like the change was too slow and too peaceful. Well, you can change the world if you want to. And we have found out that that's not always true, but to a certain point you can, if the time is right. This is Tom Gaudifroy. I'm Dutch guy. A Dutch guy who studied architecture and was an early member of what's now known as the Feetzer's
发生在海牙、蒂尔堡和代尔夫特等地。但对于许多自行车活动家来说，感觉变化太慢、太温和了。嗯，如果你想的话，你可以改变世界。我们发现这并不总是真的，但在一定程度上你可以，如果时机成熟的话。这是汤姆·高迪弗罗伊（Tom Gaudifroy）。一个荷兰人。一个学习建筑学并成为现在被称为“Fietsersbond”早期成员的荷兰人。
Bond. The Dutch Cyclist Union was established in 1975 and if stopped to Kindermort help but traffic safety on the National Agenda, it was the Cyclist Union that really pushed the creation of better cycling infrastructure, street by street, town by town. Members of the Cyclist Union sometimes took street design into their own hands. As an example, Tom told me about a number of one-way streets in the middle of Denboss, the town where he lived. The one-way streets were fine for cars, but they made it so that cyclists had to make long
荷兰自行车手联盟成立于1975年，如果说“停止杀害儿童”将交通安全提上了国家议程，那么正是自行车手联盟真正推动了更好的自行车基础设施的建设，一条街一条街，一个城镇一个城镇。自行车手联盟的成员有时会亲自接管街道设计。作为一个例子，汤姆告诉我关于他居住的城镇登博斯（Den Bosch）中间的一些单行道。单行道对汽车来说没问题，但它们使得骑行者必须绕很远的路
detours to get where they wanted to go. Cyclists in the city decided they wanted a designated contral flow lane that would allow them to ride in the opposite direction of traffic. They talked with the city. Nothing happened. So at a certain point, we said we have to do something about it.
才能到达他们想去的地方。市里的骑行者决定他们想要一条指定的逆行车道，允许他们与交通方向相反地骑行。他们与市政府谈过。什么也没发生。所以到了一定时候，我们说我们必须对此做点什么。
In the middle of the night, a group of 10 or 12 cyclists went out to the street themselves and started carefully painting a bike lane by hand. And we were nearly finished to please arrive and they said, what are you doing boys? And we said, well, we are doing some work for the municipality. We had to do still four meters. They let us finish the job and then it took us to the police office and said, we should never do that again.
在深夜，一群10到12名骑行者亲自走上街头，开始小心翼翼地手工绘制自行车道。我们快完成时警察到了，他们说：“孩子们，你们在干什么？”我们说：“好吧，我们正在为市政府做一些工作。”我们还得再做四米。他们让我们完成了工作，然后把我们带到警察局，说我们再也不应该那样做了。
Tom still cracks himself up thinking about this whole escapade and how they taunted the city about it. Oh, we also said them a bill for doing the work. And then they said yeah we were planning to do it, now we have to do it again and then we said well you can use ours, there's no problem. As the 1970s gave way to do it again, and then we said, well, you can use ours. There's no problem. As the 1970s gave way to the 1980s, the cyclist Union moved from this kind of direct action into something a lot more mundane, but arguably more influential, data gathering.
汤姆想到整个冒险经历以及他们如何嘲弄市政府时，仍然忍不住笑。哦，我们还给他们寄了一张工作账单。然后他们说：“是的，我们正计划做这件事，现在我们不得不重做一遍。”然后我们说：“好吧，你可以用我们的，没问题。”随着70年代让位于80年代，自行车手联盟从这种直接行动转向了一些更平凡，但可以说更有影响力的事情：数据收集。
The Union had realized that city planners didn't have the kind of information they needed to make the best decisions about cycling infrastructure. And so they set out to survey their members in meticulous detail about all the problems they faced when biking. To narrow road space available for cycling, traffic lights which were not adjusted to the needs of cyclists, different crossings of roads which are very dangerous, high speeds. Eventually, the union developed a lot of expertise. And what kind of road design was best for cyclists?
联盟意识到，城市规划者没有他们需要的关于自行车基础设施的最佳决策信息。因此，他们着手对成员进行细致的调查，了解他们在骑行时面临的所有问题。狭窄的道路空间、未根据骑行者需求调整的交通灯、非常危险的道路交叉口、高速行驶。最终，联盟积累了大量的专业知识。什么样的道路设计最适合骑行者？
And they eventually assembled a design manual with guidelines. It was written in a style that would be familiar to traffic engineers. And then we went to the Ministry of Transport and said, well, we have made this and we think that this should deserve a further development. And it took some years, but they said that is a very good idea. And they took over the responsibility of the projects.
他们最终汇编了一本带有指导方针的设计手册。它的写作风格是交通工程师所熟悉的。然后我们去了交通部，说：“好吧，我们已经制定了这个，我们认为这应该值得进一步发展。”这花了几年的时间，但他们说这是一个非常好的主意。他们接管了项目的责任。
The first official government version was published in 1993. It codified all kinds of things that cycling activists had been advocating for nearly 30 years. And I just want to pause here to contemplate what an amazing feat this was. It was ordinary cyclists, organized by the Union, that helped to write the Bible for bike-friendly road design in the Netherlands. It's the same manual with some updates that's in use across the country today, and that people from all over the world hope to emulate.
第一个官方政府版本于1993年出版。它编纂了自行车活动家近30年来一直倡导的各种事项。我只想在这里停顿一下，思考这是一项多么了不起的壮举。正是由联盟组织的普通骑行者，帮助编写了荷兰自行车友好型道路设计的“圣经”。这就是今天在全国范围内使用并经过一些更新的手册，也是世界各地人们希望效仿的手册。
The effectiveness of the cycling movement in the Netherlands was a sort of perfect storm of historical factors, says historian Ruth Oldenzeel. There's not one thing that's sort of the desilfable that, you know, if you have a compact city, you have cycling. No. Or if you have a great social movement, you have cycling. No.
历史学家露丝·奥尔登泽尔说，荷兰自行车运动的有效性是一场历史因素的完美风暴。没有一件事是决定性的，你知道，如果你有一个紧凑的城市，你就有自行车运动。不。或者如果你有一个伟大的社会运动，你就有自行车运动。不。
Or you have cycling paths. You get cycling. No. So it has to come together. But what's unique in the Netherlands is this high rate of cycling, the memory that people had, they knew what they were defending, and it was threatened. In the Netherlands, you had the historic preservationists fighting against the destruction of old cities,
或者你有自行车道。你就有自行车运动。不。所以它必须结合在一起。但在荷兰独特的是这种高骑行率，人们拥有的记忆，他们知道自己在捍卫什么，而且它受到了威胁。在荷兰，你有历史保护主义者反对破坏古城，
and then the anarchists imbuing the bicycle with symbolic meaning and political importance, and then stopped to kindermore, making traffic safety, a moral issue for the entire country, and then the cyclist union, becoming engineering nerd nerds and actually changing infrastructure across the country. It's an incredible sequence of events, which also makes it hard to duplicate. But at least in the Netherlands, the results have been dramatic. By many measures, it is now the cycling capital of the world.
然后是无政府主义者赋予自行车象征意义和政治重要性，然后是“停止杀害儿童”，使交通安全成为整个国家的道德问题，然后是自行车手联盟，成为工程书呆子，真正改变了全国的基础设施。这是一系列令人难以置信的事件，这也使得它很难复制。但至少在荷兰，结果是戏剧性的。从许多指标来看，它现在是世界自行车之都。
But there have been trade-offs. The cycling movement was so successful that in many ways it disappeared into the government bureaucracy. Activists from the cyclist union moved into jobs within the Ministry of Transport. And stopped the Kindermord eventually merged with safe traffic Netherlands, the group that was all about getting your kid in a yellow jacket. The merger caused much bitterness for the remaining members of the group,
但也有权衡。自行车运动非常成功，以至于在许多方面它消失在政府官僚机构中。来自自行车手联盟的活动家进入了交通部工作。而“停止杀害儿童”最终与“安全交通荷兰”合并，后者是一个专注于让你的孩子穿上黄色夹克的组织。这次合并给该组织剩余的成员带来了许多痛苦，
who felt like their activist edge was being dulled. The result is there's no longer much of a cycling movement in the Netherlands trying to push things further still. And so the numbers have remained stubbornly fixed over the past two decades. Today, 27% of trips in the Netherlands are made by bike. Which is very impressive. Here's Marco de Bromelstrod again.
他们觉得他们的激进边缘正在被磨平。结果是荷兰不再有太多的自行车运动试图进一步推动事情。因此，过去二十年来，数字一直顽固地固定不变。今天，荷兰27%的出行是骑自行车完成的。这非常令人印象深刻。这是马可·德·布罗梅尔斯特罗德再次发言。
But it's also very stable already for 20-25 years. This number is 27%, which means that 73% of all trips in the Netherlands are not done by bicycle. And that is something that we now almost have to accept. We lost the activist voice, that's something that we lost. For Marco, it feels like the Netherlands had a shot at building a real utopia. The cycling movement had a chance to kick cars out of the city entirely and to make streets public space again. But instead, they settled for coexistence. The country now has excellent transit infrastructure across the board, for buses, trains, bikes,
但它在过去20到25年里也非常稳定。这个数字是27%，这意味着荷兰73%的出行不是通过自行车完成的。这是我们现在几乎不得不接受的事实。我们失去了激进的声音，这是我们失去的东西。对马可来说，感觉荷兰曾经有机会建立一个真正的乌托邦。自行车运动曾有机会将汽车完全赶出城市，让街道重新成为公共空间。但相反，他们选择了共存。这个国家现在拥有全面的优秀交通基础设施，包括公交车、火车、自行车，
and cars. But that was not why John Lennon was in bed with a bicycle. That was not why the counter movement came with the white bicycle in the 70s. And this is something that I feel that we have lost. And this is something where I keep fighting for to bring back. It's amazing to me that even in the Netherlands, there are people who think the country hasn't gone far enough. Marco says the vanguard of the cycling movement is in other places now, where they're pushing
以及汽车。但这并不是约翰·列侬和自行车一起躺在床上的原因。那也不是70年代反主流运动提出白色自行车的原因。这是我觉得我们已经失去的东西。这也是我一直努力想要找回的东西。令我惊讶的是，即使在荷兰，也有人认为这个国家走得还不够远。马可说，自行车运动的先锋现在在其他地方，他们正在推动
the boundaries of what's possible in ways that he can't imagine the Netherlands doing anymore. There's Barcelona with its super blocks that emphasize walkability and green spaces, and Paris with its mayor who won re-election by promising to create a city where everything you need is within a 15-minute walk. They're also in the process of closing the streets around schools to cars entirely. To be honest, while I get that the Netherlands has lost some of its utopian momentum, it still looks like a utopia from where I sit.
可能性的边界，以他无法想象荷兰还能做到的方式。比如巴塞罗那，它的超级街区强调步行和绿地；还有巴黎，其市长通过承诺创建一个一切所需都在15分钟步行范围内的城市而赢得了连任。他们还在逐步将学校周围的街道完全禁止汽车通行。老实说，虽然我明白荷兰失去了一些乌托邦的动力，但在我看来，它看起来仍然像是一个乌托邦。
I ride my bike a fair amount in the town where I live, and I ride with my kids. Every time I do, I feel a little nervous, and like maybe I shouldn't. Like maybe it's even irresponsible, given the lack of bike lanes. And the fact that drivers here just don't have much awareness about bikes. And I mean, sure, I wouldn't mind being at the cutting edge in a place like Barcelona or Paris, but I'd also take what Amsterdam
我在我居住的城镇经常骑自行车，也和我的孩子们一起骑。每次我这样做，我都感到有点紧张，觉得也许我不应该这样做。觉得考虑到缺乏自行车道，这甚至可能是不负责任的。而且这里司机对自行车的意识确实不高。我的意思是，当然，我不介意在巴塞罗那或巴黎这样的地方处于前沿，但我也会接受阿姆斯特丹
or any city in the Netherlands has any day of the week. My oldest kid learned to ride a bike this past fall. At our local park, she kicked off on her pink two-wheeler and cruised down the sidewalk before wobbling to a stop. You were doing it! She was grinning, so proud to be moving on her own. And I was so proud to see her do it. That was awesome. Way to go, kid. That was awesome. And of course, I felt just a
或荷兰任何城市所拥有的，随时都可以。我最大的孩子去年秋天学会了骑自行车。在我们当地的公园里，她蹬着粉红色的两轮车，沿着人行道滑行，然后摇摇晃晃地停了下来。你做到了！她咧着嘴笑，为能自己移动感到非常自豪。看到她做到这一点，我也感到非常自豪。那太棒了。干得好，孩子。那太棒了。当然，我也感到一丝
tinge of fear too, which I hate. It's the kind of thing that makes you want to call up some friends. Maybe sit in the middle of a road, make some makeshift speed bumps, or put in a bike lane under the cover of night. Coming up after the break, the bicycle-related grudge between the Dutch and the Germans that's been going on for almost 80 years. We are back with senior editor, Jolani Hall to talk even more about cycling history in the Netherlands.
恐惧，我很讨厌这种感觉。这正是那种让你想打电话给朋友的事情。也许坐在马路中间，做一些临时的减速带，或者在夜幕掩护下安装一条自行车道。休息之后，我们将讨论荷兰人和德国人之间持续了近80年的自行车恩怨。我们回到了高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔身边，进一步谈论荷兰的自行车历史。
Yes, that's right. More by history. Yeah, I mean, I wanted to, to include just a little bit more because in the story we skipped right over the 1940s and World War II, but there's actually some kind of fascinating stuff from that era that I wanted to tell you about. I can see where you cut it out because listeners aren't privy to this, but there's almost a point in every single story where World War II is a part of the story. Right. To the point where it becomes like a cliche in our stories then, like, yeah, we're all just slightly sick of it. Exactly, exactly. Exactly. I know. I know. But this is actually an especially good World War II tangents.
是的，没错。更多关于历史的内容。是的，我的意思是，我想多包含一点，因为在故事中我们直接跳过了20世纪40年代和二战，但那个时代实际上有一些非常迷人的东西，我想告诉你。我能看出你为什么把它剪掉了，因为听众不知道这些，但几乎每个故事里都有一个点，二战是故事的一部分。对。以至于它在我们的故事中变得像陈词滥调一样，就像，是的，我们都对此有点厌倦了。完全正确，完全正确。完全正确。我知道。我知道。但这确实是一个特别好的二战插曲。
So, okay. Well, then I will allow it. Okay. So, so by the time World War II rolled around in the Netherlands, Dutch cyclists, especially in Amsterdam, had developed something of a reputation for being rule-breakers. They were known for just blowing through stop signs, riding slowly down the middle of the road, and annoying cars, stuff like that. They were sort of like a 1940s version of critical mass. And kind of anarchic in their style. And apparently when the Nazis invaded the Netherlands in 1940,
好吧，那我就允许它。好的。那么，当二战在荷兰爆发时，荷兰的骑行者，特别是在阿姆斯特丹，已经形成了一种不守规矩的名声。他们以无视停车标志、在马路中间缓慢骑行、惹恼汽车等行为而闻名。他们就像是40年代版的“关键群体”（Critical Mass）。他们的风格有点无政府主义。显然，当纳粹在1940年入侵荷兰时，
they were pretty taken aback by this behavior. When the Nazis arrived, they were quite shocked and pissed. So this is Pete Jordan. He's an American who's lived in Amsterdam for a couple decades. And he wrote a book about the history of Amsterdam cycling called in the city of Bikes. Here they were, they just conquered the country and they expected to be respected. And yet the cyclists repeatedly ignored numerous rules that were implemented by the Nazis. Even to the point where Pete argues, one of the biggest forms of ordinary everyday resistance to the Nazi occupiers was the cyclists themselves who were not gonna change their ways
他们对这种行为感到非常吃惊。当纳粹到达时，他们感到非常震惊和愤怒。这就是皮特·乔丹。他是一位在阿姆斯特丹住了几十年的美国人。他写了一本关于阿姆斯特丹自行车历史的书，叫《自行车之城》。他们刚刚征服了这个国家，本以为会受到尊重。然而，骑行者们却一再无视纳粹实施的众多规则。甚至皮特认为，对纳粹占领者最普通的日常抵抗形式之一，就是这些骑行者，他们不会因为德国人在那里就改变自己的方式
just because the Germans were there. Wow, that's so amazing. Yeah, and the clashes between the Nazis and the Dutch cyclists only escalated. What happened was that in 1942, the Nazis first banned Jewish people from owning, renting or borrowing bikes, and they required people to actually turn their bikes in. And then not long after that, it became clear that
。哇，那太神奇了。是的，纳粹和荷兰骑行者之间的冲突不断升级。发生的事情是，1942年，纳粹首先禁止犹太人拥有、租用或借用自行车，并要求人们上交自行车。在那之后不久，很明显
the Nazis had plans to confiscate bikes more widely. And when the word leaked out about it, it led to this mad scramble. Thousands of people rushing to get their bicycles off the streets, hiding them in their apartments, hiding them in their attics. I found stories of people bearing them in their backyards, trying to do anything to keep the bikes, of course, for themselves, but also not to fall into enemy hands. And in the end, the Nazis were still able to get their hands
纳粹有更广泛地没收自行车的计划。当消息传出时，导致了一场疯狂的争抢。成千上万的人冲上街头取回他们的自行车，把它们藏在公寓里，藏在阁楼里。我发现了人们把它们埋在后院的故事，试图做任何事情来保留这些自行车，当然是为了自己，也是为了不落入敌手。最终，纳粹还是能够得到
on a lot of bikes, which they used for their own transportation, but they also melted them down and recycled the metal. Or in some cases, they even used parts of them as ironwork, kind of like makeshift rebar when they were building bunkers. Wow, that is fast name. Yeah. So when the war ended, the scale of Nazi theft was finally fully understood and quantified.
很多自行车，他们用这些自行车作为自己的交通工具，但也把它们熔化并回收金属。或者在某些情况下，他们甚至在建造掩体时把零件当作铁制品，类似于临时的钢筋。哇，那太迷人了。是的。所以当战争结束时，纳粹盗窃的规模终于被完全理解和量化了。
And it turned out that over the course of their five-year occupation, they stole everything from factory machinery, hospital equipment to library books and museum artifacts, and of course vehicles as well. So the Nazis stole thousands of cars and trucks and millions of bikes. The Dutch Central Statistics Bureau estimated that there were four million bikes in the Netherlands before the war, and afterwards only two million of them remained. Wow, that is a lot of bicycles stolen by the Nazis. I know, and it also shows you sort of the scale of bicycle use at the time. Yeah.
结果发现，在他们五年的占领期间，他们偷走了从工厂机器、医院设备到图书馆书籍和博物馆文物，当然还有车辆。所以纳粹偷走了成千上万的汽车和卡车，以及数百万辆自行车。荷兰中央统计局估计，战前荷兰有400万辆自行车，战后只剩下200万辆。哇，那真是被纳粹偷走了很多自行车。我知道，这也向你展示了当时自行车使用的规模。是的。
Still half of them, and there'd still be millions left of them. Some bicycles left, you, exactly. And apparently this bike theft proved to be an especially sore point with the Dutch. Pete says that starting in the 1950s, when German tourists would show up in the Netherlands, and try to order a beer in a cafe or something they would hear this reply, airsman feats to roof, first give me back my. First, give me back my bicycle. First, give me back my bicycle, and then I'll serve you a beer. So the phrase is Airstman feets Tarouk, and it means first return my bike.
仍然有一半，而且还会剩下数百万辆。剩下一些自行车，你，完全正确。显然，这种自行车盗窃被证明是荷兰人特别痛心的一点。皮特说，从20世纪50年代开始，当德国游客出现在荷兰，试图在咖啡馆点啤酒之类的东西时，他们会听到这样的回答：“Airstman feets Tarouk”，首先把我的自行车还给我。首先，把我的自行车还给我。首先，把我的自行车还给我，然后我再给你上一杯啤酒。所以这句话是“Airstman feets Tarouk”，意思是首先归还我的自行车。
And this really became a thing that Dutch people would say to German people, like over multiple generations. So I'm so charmed for this. Okay, so this is something that still comes up to this day. Well, Pete said it's faded somewhat in the present day, but for a number of decades, it was really a thing. And there are so many good examples in Pete's book that might give you a sense of how it kind of built up over time. For example, he described how in 1965, the crown princess of the Netherlands got engaged to a
这真的成了荷兰人会对德国人说的一句话，跨越了好几代人。我被这个迷住了。好的，所以这是至今仍然会出现的事情。嗯，皮特说它在今天已经有所淡化，但在几十年的时间里，它确实是一回事。皮特的书里有很多很好的例子，可能会让你感觉到它是如何随着时间积累起来的。例如，他描述了1965年，荷兰王储与一位
German, and the two of them went on a tour of Amsterdam. It was like their way of introducing the new fiancee to the capital city. And apparently a couple of Amsterdamers who were Jewish made a banner that said, return my bike, that they tried to send into the sky with 20 helium balloons that did not work. Instead, they hung it from a bridge. And I don't think that the princess or her fiance actually saw it, but the point was very clear.
德国人订婚，两人去阿姆斯特丹巡游。这就像是他们向首都介绍新未婚夫的方式。显然，一对犹太裔阿姆斯特丹人制作了一条横幅，上面写着“归还我的自行车”，他们试图用20个氦气球把它送上天空，但没有成功。相反，他们把它挂在了一座桥上。我不认为公主或她的未婚夫真的看到了它，但重点非常明确。
It was like, we don't like this German dude. Give us our bikes back. Neelan versus Deutschland. Done. It seems like one of the ways the phrase got more popular is that in the 1970s, the phrase was adopted by Dutch soccer fans. In the World Cup Final 1974. So, for example, during the 1974 World Cup, the Netherlands ended up playing West Germany in the final.
就像是，我们不喜欢这个德国家伙。把我们的自行车还给我们。尼德兰对德国。完成了。似乎这句话变得更流行的方式之一是，在20世纪70年代，这句话被荷兰足球迷采用了。在1974年世界杯决赛中。所以，例如，在1974年世界杯期间，荷兰最终在决赛中对阵西德。
And fans in the stands held banners that said, first, return my bike. Wow, they are persistent. Yeah, they're very persistent. And it seems like the use of the phrase continued at least into the 80s or 90s. Pete told me about the example of a friend of his who moved from Germany to Amsterdam in the 80s.
看台上的球迷举着横幅，上面写着“首先，归还我的自行车”。哇，他们真执着。是的，他们非常执着。而且这句话的使用似乎至少持续到了80年代或90年代。皮特告诉我一个朋友的例子，他在80年代从德国搬到了阿姆斯特丹。
He worked as a music teacher in the primary schools. And apparently when kids heard his accent, they would regularly ask him to give their bikes back, or to give their father or grandfather's bike back. And the interesting thing is these kids were at that point very far removed in time and sometimes even geography from the wartime bicycle thefts. And some of these children were so young,
他在小学当音乐老师。显然，当孩子们听到他的口音时，他们会经常要求他把他们的自行车还回来，或者把他们父亲或祖父的自行车还回来。有趣的是，这些孩子当时在时间和地理上都离战时的自行车盗窃非常遥远。其中一些孩子还很小，
they of course they were born long after the war. Their parents probably weren't even born during the war. And many of these children had immigrant backgrounds, yet somehow they even knew to say that to a German, a native German person. And am I getting the right impression that this is kind of a bit, like that this is an ongoing joke that they're using, you know,
他们当然是在战后很久才出生的。他们的父母可能在战争期间甚至还没出生。而且这些孩子中许多有移民背景，但不知何故，他们甚至知道对一个德国人、一个土生土长的德国人说这句话。我得到的印象对吗，这有点像是一个他们正在使用的持续不断的笑话，你知道，
this obviously really dark part of their history to kind of, you know, make some light of it. Yeah, I actually asked Pete about this because I wanted to make sure I was understanding the context of it. And in his book, he acknowledges that this was a really complicated time in Dutch history. He talks about the ways that the cyclists resisted, for example, but there was also a lot
利用他们历史上这段显然非常黑暗的部分来，你知道，让它变得轻松一点。是的，我确实问过皮特这个问题，因为我想确保我理解了它的背景。在他的书中，他承认这是荷兰历史上一个非常复杂的时期。他谈到了骑行者抵抗的方式，例如，但也有很多
of collaboration that happens between Dutch officials and the Nazis. And so the first my bike back phrase grew out of that complicated history and the country's genuinely dark and horrific experience of the war. But Pete said that his perception is that as time has passed, the phrase has become something more like a running joke, you know, a dark running joke in a lot of ways. Yeah. Well, this is so fascinating. I'm so glad I know about, give us back our bikes first.
荷兰官员和纳粹之间的合作。所以“把我的自行车还给我”这句话就是从那段复杂的历史和国家真正黑暗和可怕的战争经历中成长起来的。但皮特说，他的看法是，随着时间的推移，这句话已经变得更像是一个持续的笑话，你知道，在很多方面是一个黑暗的持续笑话。是的。好吧，这太迷人了。我很高兴我知道“先把我们的自行车还给我们”。
This is such a good part of the story. Thank you so much, Delaney, appreciate it. Well thank you, Roman. 99% of us was produced this week by Delaney Hall with research and production assistance from Lota von Hollen. Lota also did her damnedest to help us with the pronunciation of the Dutch names and words. Any mistakes are purely our own.
这是故事中非常好的一部分。非常感谢你，德莱尼，很感激。谢谢你，罗曼。《99% Invisible》本周由德莱尼·霍尔制作，洛塔·冯·霍伦提供研究和制作协助。洛塔也尽了最大努力帮助我们发音荷兰语的名字和单词。任何错误纯属我们自己的。
The story was edited by Emmet Fitzgerald. Original music by Swan Riel, sound mixed by Martin Gonzalez, fact checking by Graham Haysha. Kurt Colstad is our digital director, Residine, includes Chris Barube, Christopher Johnson, Jason Dalyone, Vivian Leigh, Jacob Muldinano Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars.
这个故事由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德编辑。原创音乐由斯旺·里尔创作，声音混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯完成，事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙完成。库尔特·科尔斯塔德是我们的数字总监，制作团队包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、杰森·戴利昂、薇薇安·李、雅各布·穆尔迪纳诺·梅迪纳、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格、索菲亚·克拉茨克和我，罗曼·马斯。
The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. Special thanks this week to OVT and VPRO Radio for allowing us to use excerpts of their interview with Vic Longanoff, and to Chris Baima, who provided voiceover for Vic's tape. Extra special thanks to Hank Young Decker, whose book, Cycling Pathways, really helped us understand the cycling movement in the Netherlands, but whose interview didn't make it into the episode, for anyone who wants a deep dive into this history, Hank Young's book is excellent and very comprehensive. Bartlett, thanks to Steven Shapel and Martin Monson.
《99% Invisible》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。本周特别感谢OVT和VPRO电台允许我们使用他们采访维克·隆加诺夫的片段，以及为维克的录音提供配音的克里斯·拜马。特别感谢汉克·杨·德克尔，他的书《自行车路径》确实帮助我们了解了荷兰的自行车运动，但他的采访没有进入这一集，对于任何想要深入了解这段历史的人来说，汉克·杨的书非常出色且非常全面。巴特利特，感谢史蒂文·沙佩尔和马丁·蒙森。
99% invisible is part of the Stitcher and Series XM podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to others to your shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《99% Invisible》是Stitcher和Series XM播客家族的一部分。现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。我们也在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他节目的链接，以及《99PI》的每一集往期节目。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。